koné dit ouah
il est dans les temps
[Musique]
je suis prêt mais c'est super coccinelle
coccinelle c'est un des noms de code au
hockey je vois les coccinelles sont
censés avoir de la chance
tu n'as pas la poisse tu crois ma poisse
est légendaire même quand je veux tuer
personne il ya des morts tu te souviens
du groupe suicidaire temps mais
l'hôpital accroche toi bon quand il ya
mort ok et le mariage tequila
johannesburg
il faut se réinventer si vous voulez un
plan simple pour ton retour aux affaires
y a pas plus simple
il faut trouver celui qui après la
mallette
c'est trop facile oh merde quoi tu te
souviens des deux tares et en bolivie
des juments oui jumeaux j'ai un doute
descendre ce sera
[Musique]
tu as essayé de me planter tout
je n'arrêterai jamais de poursuivre
coire
j'ai raté mon mari et il se trame autre
chose salut tu te souviens pas de moi tu
ressembles à tous les blancs sdf que
j'ai vue dans ma vie non mais sérieux tu
te souviens pas moi
va bouffer des que toi non pardon pardon
je vois un psy j'y travaille et 100
prochaines années aux salaires tellement
facile dit comme ça juste une piqûre et
tu sais ce qui se passe ton 106 qui fit
des phénix
merde vous allez vouloir entendre
toute l'histoire qu'est ce qui nous
attendra que tourner un mot blanche avec
son armée d' assassin on a un taré à la
tête de la plus grande organisation
criminelle en activité de toute la
planète qui va le défoncer loupé
ac la mort blanche ne laissera des sont
de simples
faut qu'on ait un plan
[Musique]
devoir faire du mal à des gens
qu'est ce qui était arrivé ça peut être
un petit traumatisme crânien
il faut que je descende nostra
désolé mon grand
donne